the body cam footage starts off with the
officer walking into the lunchroom where
a fight had just erupted at palo verde
high school with pepper spray in his
hand he takes a look at one student on
the ground then moves on to the student
that would be restrained by the neck you
can see the student is being held back
by other staff members and then you hear
him telling the student to settle down
then threatening her with inappropriate
language
the video then shows the officer
throwing the students to the ground if
you look here the video shows the
officer with his arm over her face and
nose which the student first told us
about when we spoke to her last month
because it wasn't noticeable in this
cell phone video the ccsd police
lieutenant denied it at the time but
this body cam video clearly showing
otherwise the inappropriate language
continues
you better chill
you understand me
you ready to chill the student is able
to move her face away from the officer's
arm
the student is complying with what the
officer is telling her he then handcuffs
her and walks away with her